entre sonrisas y abrazos saltos y cantos
las agrupaciones feministas celebraron
la despenalización del aborto hasta la
semana 24 de gestación en colombia a
partir de ahora se aplicará un sistema
mixto que se une a la ley de 355 de 2006
que permite interrumpir el embarazo en
tres causales se había riesgo para la
salud de la mujer en caso de violación o
malformación del feto esto es un logro
que tenemos que defender y que tiene que
aplicarse y tiene que garantizarse las
mujeres no van a ser perseguidas ni
criminalizar la coalición causa justa
movimiento que engloba a distintas
organizaciones feministas estima que
unas 400 mujeres fueron condenadas o
sancionadas por abortar desde 2006
incluyendo al menos 80 menores de 18
años y alertan de que el 90% de los
abortos en el país se realizan de forma
clandestina muchas veces poniendo en
riesgo la vida de las mujeres que buscan
alternativas inseguras grupos
detractores de la medida también se
manifestaron a las afueras de la sede de
la corte constitucional
es una noticia triste
[Música]
en las feministas creen que eso es un
avance con las mujeres pero en realidad
es un retroceso
lucha por los derechos de las mujeres
colombia se suma así a la lista de
países donde el aborto sale fuera del
código penal como argentina uruguay o
cuba un fallo histórico que ubica la
nación a la cabeza de américa latina' en
derechos sexuales y reproductivos
[Música]